yo what's good this megs and you're
watching the tucson cipher on bootleg
kev's podcast
check check check it smartly be man
let's do it like this
broken complex in this [ __ ] watch look
imma just start with the statement
everyone pay what you hold
i ain't just talking to tucson this for
the state is a hole i'm seeing to listen
to making the low but die in the night
and debate with the trolls i hear all
this talk about
[Music]
was overlooked now i'm right on time and
i'm stressed out cause i'm overbooked
guess the comments y'all making quick
another fast rapper ain't saying [ __ ]
like
[ __ ] man now it ain't my first day and
this i mean say you're different don't
stop me stressed don't let the way you
damn just get it off your chest
everyday that i'm getting older i listen
more and i'm talking less so
take what you get from me in the state i
made history born to breathe in this
southwest terror spit it out like it's
listerine it's a gift to me and i know
so i'ma keep pushing and laying these
vogues from arizona been taking it close
to ugly as molly on all of the socials
ladies and gentlemen
i go by the name of soul point as you
may know
[Music]
look
[Applause]
[Music]
how much longer like this they don't get
the time of day given the amount
that i spent i sense the vibe is in my
tents but it's cool you're now tuned
into the southwest about 10.
step up your game you're making mild
attempts probably spend your nights and
weekends hanging out with some friends i
spent my nights and weekends getting
right with this pen
now my style of flow will make this
rapper's file exam
i'm like a-rod with the j-lo burrowing
on the way home
highway patrol up ahead say let's break
slow
they smell the smoke but let us go bro
that came close
smooth talk cause our moon walk away we
go
look at you dead in the eyes we don't
let anyone slide
back in the day they didn't like me i
got no reason to lie
now i'm a head of the bank bout to make
several deposits
i need a million dollars wait i need a
million dollars
then my love i put in overtime never
doubt no that i got em
middle fingers if you hate it on me face
to face what's the problem
now we know there's no problem talking
low you on the bottom
letting them in with your dicey cut them
off i gotta drop them
level up the gas pedal stuff 90 buick
with the wide seats
grind me moving what you might see few
tricks under my sleeve
can't tell if i'ma introduce them to a
new breed or a dying breed
arizona where you'll find me 850 believe
in my veins i get up and then i go
i don't think it's ever over weight of
the world on my shoulders
i never quit i never flow anyone up on
my bed would
some of them did when i went for it they
really thought they were meant for it
mood changed when i set foot stepping
inside of the building
looking around like for real you telling
me the music i'm playing outside don't
sound like a deal
[ __ ] it i'll go get the meal burn the
row and i'm chilling
smoke dripping from the ceiling it don't
matter how you feel
cash landscape low arizona [ __ ] shout
out bootleg care for this one man
[Music]
yeah uh
it ain't a game who we allow amongst us
and god we trust don't
mention arizona without you mentioning
us ah let me set my pace
nah let me run my race uh if the shoot
fits when it happens imma lace my ace
this elevation that is highest
motivation at its finest
[Music]
they can't see the vision i'm spitting
them braille so i know they can fail
we only learn lesson no taking no else
from the land of the bells
they crossing the border and homer
cartel they profit our prisons they know
what's gonna sell they breaking the
ignorance [ __ ] is gonna sell
mama told me get it how you live boy i
don't care how you do it just be
a man boy ah and you can tell that her
son was listening lasky [ __ ] went
bootleg like this to prohibition
[Music]
y'all know it's a game right
[Applause]
[Music]
reporting from the jungle [ __ ] this
planet of the ace my tea came from
bathing ape they have me tuned i nice
just skate huh
pouring the baby i'm making the [ __ ]
drop i'm like a step dad
industry [ __ ] they lagging the
backbone i wanna accept that
running through netherlands they hit
ain't got horses i need a hellcat
white upper nose a diet plan supplements
and divided blend said i saw the judge
and i lied again
hey yeah my dog bringing out the ghost
my [ __ ] writing different
last week they bury kevin go i'm writing
different
city legend i'm taking flowers i been
deserved it
when i die parade mikhail center for the
service
eight
[Music]
yeah it's tommy from the five dog
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah back to fitness pray for moneybags
that's sacrilegious
you gonna pay to see this class you want
a campus visit
i need my number in my bank account with
matching digits
if i ever raise the bars like i'm
tracking fitness
you don't live behind your bars i know
you like a witness
cause you really in the cutter that's a
bad decision
so they said i'm playing games i gotta
activision
but i don't never love no thought cause
that's a bad decision
heard the beat and told myself what
would belly do let's run it
no relaxing drop some acid say some [ __ ]
that's hard to stomach
i deliver way i move around and put
these things in motion
and i know it's hard to digest need some
space and use a colon
if you find a better cook up put my keys
to the chef the only way i die a
reasonable death
i've been hungry too forever my ambition
just like celiac kids gluttony
something i condone don't hear me rap
deadbeat
i ain't even pick up the kids i know my
contract got a clause for all these
gifts that i give
but if there's beef make kebabs i'll put
the stick to his ribs
leave the mask inside the dumpster take
a lift to the crib
where i work got my mind going crazy i'm
out the box
this ain't dead stop walking my shoes
and circle the block keep it up honey
here
ben ah key you get the reference penny
for your thoughts i'm investing in your
attention
when the dust settle rain so long i've
seen it rush metal
i ain't never seen you gas you barely
touched petal i wrote the manual my pen
so loud you hear it rev you saw it first
right here
like a bootleg and that's where the kev
went to my city show my heart ain't got
to keep so when you say i got the juice
that's the only thing i see arizona to
the dirt and for the five i live and
breathe so you can hang it we can grow
all depends on different trees whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah karma that's my [ __ ] but i'm
[ __ ] with lady luck i told the world
i'm finna grind
until my race is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do